uh this is part two of our interview
with rodney scott former head of border
patrol under the trump administration
and the bite administration thanks for
being here
thank you for having me it's my honor so
after all your years i mean how would
you describe the importance of border
security it's just like your home if you
do not know who's coming into your home
you have no security
if we can't control and know who's
coming into this country we don't have
any homeland security and the the most
frustrating part was
that for my career for the vast majority
of my career we were making significant
progress we were making smart
investments we were getting better and
better control of the border our
confidence level and being able to say
we knew who and what crossed it was not
a hundred percent but it was getting
significantly better than ever before
and it allowed us
to make calculated risk decisions on
behalf of americans we knew who the
organizations were bringing them and we
had a higher confidence level of what
type of a risk would they be if they
crossed in this area where they're
trying to evade arrest higher
probability that they're actually
criminal aliens or they're narcotic
smugglers we were investing in
technology systems that use artificial
intelligence to help us with that as
well all that has been shut down and all
effort has been refocused on expediting
the processing speed of the massive
amounts of illegal aliens that are
coming into the country today
that should matter because if i can't
tell you who crosses through a nogales
or a mcallen or a san diego they're they
are going to end up in your community so
in that case it is fairly open no the
border's wide open right now
wide open if the border is wide open
right now border patrol is well beyond
what i would call task saturation they
are so overwhelmed there are huge
sections of the u.s border and you pick
the state we know we have thousands of
people waiting to come across and where
we know we have
like like high level cartel violence
going on on a daily basis between the
government of mexico
and the cartels and they're bringing
narcotics in there are hundreds of miles
of border there's not a single border
patrol agent right now why
because they're in a soft sided facility
that we set up at another five to six
million dollars a month to babysit to
process and to expedite the processing
of these people i've fought for it my
whole career you can be pro-border
security pro-law and order and
pro-immigration it just has to be legal
you can't have unabated illegal entry
into this country
and have any real belief that you have
border security and if you have no
border security you have no homeland
security no national security the remain
in mexico program what that did was it
ensured due process
so that anybody could get a chance to
basically claim asylum
but it took away the prize before the ju
the judge made a decision
so it really weeded out the fraud what
people miss in that is by weeding out
those thousands and thousands of fraud
cases people that actually literally
legitimately need asylum can get it
quicker and easier because it's the same
number of people processing all these
cases so
again why change that wasn't that
something that was working i can't get
into the why and speculate but i can
tell you that it was working it
dramatically changed the border dynamics
for us and it eliminated the asylum
fraud as soon as people knew they
weren't going to get released into the
u.s and have six to seven years to hide
before their court date they stopped
applying because the case wasn't valid
to begin with and you feel it's
important to speak out now i think it's
very important to speak out now
there's
there's a lot of people within dhs that
want to tell the story
within border patrol with an ice with an
ero but they're within the confines of
the of the structure
and i don't think it's a surprise to
anybody that on january 20th basically a
gag order came down where none of those
officials are allowed to say anything to
anybody unless it's all pre-approved so
that's why i pushed for the
congressional hearings that's why i
didn't come out day one say anything
because i think that's the proper way to
do it
if they're called before congress
they just tell the truth
under under oath
as opposed to right now they just can't
whatever you think about border security
you need factual information which means
the whole story how many really are
being released into the u.s how many
really are being tested for covet
out of that how many are really positive
there's like there's information that
dhs has that they're making the decision
to not share with the public that
historically we would have shared were
you surprised at some of the decisions
when you heard them as you were still
border chief
as they were coming down were you
surprised that these are the
things that they were choosing to do or
not do i wouldn't say surprised but i
will tell you i kind of had a false hope
because i've heard that before you've
seen transitions of administrations
before and you say one thing and then
when they get all the facts and they
really look at things that you'll
hesitate and and you'll reconsider
there's no dialogue
there's no like team there's no
the government officials just aren't
being listened to proven proven systems
proven programs are being ignored
and i avoid the why
i'll just tell you that's what's
happening if you had carte blanche if
you had the magic wand then you could do
what you wanted on the border
to solve the problem or try to
how would you do it i would re-implement
the strategy that the united states
border patrol had been working on and
perfecting
for 25 almost 30 years
and that is just a smart mix and customs
of border protection at the ports of
entry we do that in lockstep by the way
because you'll hear people saying oh
that threat's only at the port that's
not true it goes back and forth so we
have to work together in lockstep
but we have been systematically
improving border security for years
through a smart deployment of personnel
technology and infrastructure what would
i do is that simply continue to build
out the border wall that those
requirements were developed by seasoned
border patrol agents based on where that
infrastructure could make the biggest
difference and the return on investment
long term i would continue to invest in
the people but there's got to be a
consequence for illegal entry you cannot
let people just come up wave a flag and
then release them into the u.s to get
their case heard five six years later
they've already got the prize
they're already here there's no reason
for that so you're saying that that
while it was a trump administration
policy
is not people shouldn't be
anti-political
anti-trump it's policy that the border
patrol came up with over years dhs
personnel so
this is how it worked up until january
20th
and i was actually very proud to be part
of this i didn't create it but i was
proud to be part of it people got
brought in a room from ice from cis from
the department of justice from u.s
border patrol and they were told hey how
do what can we do with what we have
we're still going to work with congress
and try to get some of these laws fixed
but in the meantime
what can we work with what can we do to
secure the border so that we can go out
and tell america we know what who and
what is crossing that border to the best
ability we possibly can so what's your
biggest fear
when you look at the border beyond the
border now what i'm seeing kind of at
the national level
is
hiding of information from the american
public so they can't even make a good
decision they can't make an educated
decision because they don't have the
information that worries me just society
in general that how it's harder and
harder to to even people listen to me
right now don't you don't have to
believe anything i say anybody that
thinks that an uneducated smuggler
bringing cocaine and marijuana across
the border that successfully gets past
border patrol agents is the only threat
is kind of naive there's a lot of other
threats and again we have to sit in a
different in a different venue for that
but i spent five years after 9 11
working on anti-terrorism issues
specifically for border patrol and cbp
and bringing us into that arena to see
what the other threats are that are out
there and they're real but we're getting
better every day to shut all that off
and to put people's lives at risk in
kansas or chicago or everywhere else
because people on the border they feel
whether they're democrats or republicans
they are passionate about this issue
correct but you're saying it should
affect every state yeah people watching
this right now i think so many of them
look at it and see that's a border
problem
they're not staying there
and those 400 000 people that avoided
arrest they clearly didn't stay at the
border they might be living down the
street from you who are they what's the
threat i just can't tell you that
because we didn't interact with them but
i can tell you we've the border patrol
arrested over 10 000 criminal aliens
last year out of the people that they
came in contact with
the other thing that gets missed
sometimes that means they've been in the
u.s before and committed a crime there's
no global database that says what crimes
these people committed in in syria or
nicaragua or honduras
at all
those 10 000 are only people that have
been here before and committed a crime
so what else just statistically if you
build that out there are some real
threats to this country that are getting
bias right now that literally all it
takes is to
re-implement some of the uh programs we
had in place
that got rid of the fraud that slowed
down the flow you're always going to
have some people trying to sneak in
illegally that's why we have a border
patrol
but they can make decisions of where
they deploy much more smarter when
you're dealing with manageable numbers
than the chaos that we have today which
from the intel i've i've seen and heard
about is nothing like what's going to
come tomorrow it's going to get so much
worse if we don't fix this thanks for
the time thanks for speaking out hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else